[Musik]
kann ich nicht ich habe mir selber songs
mobil gemacht aus glaube an weintrauben
und irgendwas anderes ich teste das erst
mal live vor der kamera hier
wenn er musik macht man packt dann nicht
eine kombination aus irgendwelche
zitrone weintrauben heidelbeeren
blaubeeren mit in den kommentaren gefahr
habe ich schon mehr tricks mit dem
kleinen finger bord kann deswegen zeige
ich euch das jetzt hier mal mein gott
ist das erste das die linie gesicht
mache mir ist aufgefallen dass wir die
tricks komplett falsch gemacht haben und
zwar muss man halt nicht so machen
sondern man muss quasi erst zurück und
dann springe ich zeige euch das mal eben
nicht immer so gemacht und das geht so
nicht richtig sondern man muss halt
sonst hinten und dann halt irgendwie so
machen also irgendwie beispielsweise
malibu ich wollte heute eigentlich gar
nicht blocken aber ich meine schaut euch
das allein an es ist wieder so krankes
wetter draußen war einmal wieder mega
sinnvoll dass ich mir gerade erst ist er
dick dann diesen eklatanten getrunken
habe auf jeden fall ist der plan dass
jona
max worten jetzt um kommen weil wir dann
zusammen für jana fahren wollten weil
die einen pool hat aber vorher leute
kämen wenn ich mal erstmal kleines
bauwerk auf dem stativ ab und er schießt
aufs tor bekommen fragt bin ich schlecht
ich werde jetzt auf jeden fall noch mal
die zähne putzen
nein da ist eine richtig fette mutter an
den dingen
ich hab da braucht man in münchen
real habe ich schon glocke sagen müssen
hier hat dagegen im mund hier voll oft
sagen wir zuschauer auf der straße
treffen alter dieses mal die wand das
ist eine stinknormale rand mit 400
millionen
er ist so heiß ich habe meinen video
fertig geschnitten meine damen und
herren was macht ihr hier auch der
spinnt schon wieder was willst du mir
zeigen
[Musik]
wir sind jetzt auf dem weg zur jahren
gehört
zuvor aus
die leute lassen sechster
egal
[Musik]
luca wie schön
[Applaus]
[Musik]
es ist schön hier was das denn her
es geht ihm jetzt also ich muss wirklich
sagen ja das ist schon sehr sehr schön
jemand läuft steine runter
die folgenden zehn muss jetzt warten wir
mal kurz was sagen und zwar wollten die
bei jana in pool gehen doch dann kamen
die nachbarskinder an die waren ihnen
die acht und sieben jahre alt und haben
uns die ganze zeit gehabt deswegen ja
seht einfach selbst sehen wir die story
von dir den jungs zu jana gefahren
ausgestiegen und dann steigen damit zum
stock und haben mich angegriffen
[Musik]
jungs gegen mädchen mädchen gegen jungs
genau meinst du die beiden jungs und
epcam fans hören warum so viel
kriminalität mit ihr beginnt nach drei
jungs für die ihren reim auf blöd
seitdem der osterhase war schon da dann
hat er euch vielleicht nichts gebracht
weil die böse jungs gibt eine oma in
arschloch was ist das geht zu weit
ein paar sekunden später
[Musik]
wo habt ihr da wenig dass rein
geschrieben
also freuen ich habe jetzt ein brief von
den jungs dann inzwischen körper in
italien fliegen
ich hoffe ich will springer mit sowas
bleiben die erst recht also man erst mal
den zweiten brief auf und da sehen wir
herr katapult mal da und schwach ich
zeige euch was ich mit der botschaft von
denen mache stimmt also wir sind jetzt
angekommen bei den eltern von den
kindern wohnen jetzt in dem man ja ich
hab mit dem anflug hallo hallo sind sie
der vater von den bösen kindern die
hängen briefe geschrieben
ja ja ja ja
damals herausgefahren und als die
flasche hatte schon wieder post für mich
darüber dass wir nicht so gut und ist
darüber gar die namen den man mal auf
post frosch du du sagst schickt also
mögen wir uns jetzt wieder fragt einfach
dein vater okay
wie wichtig ist es dir dass du am strand
oder generell wenn du dich sonst einfach
präsent ist
das teil ist und einfach das beste an da
vorne sind irgendwelche runden gedreht
aber man sieht sie jetzt gerade wenn ich
vielleicht haben wir gleich die chance
ist da jetzt wieder weg nach dass kinder
sind wieder anstatt gekommen danke der
ist gerade verschlossen
danke dir bala buluk habe wahrscheinlich
von mir oder springt wunder ist ein
typisches spiel also erwartet nicht alle
anderen telefonisch spielt einfach
weiterhin nicht sicher sei es ist
mittlerweile 17 hohe wir haben essen
gestellt wo bleibt das ist eigentlich
jungs noch mal wiedergekommen aber
irgendwie uns dann doch ein bisschen
gemerkt jetzt schon jetzt auf jeden fall
noch so für ein zwei stunden und junger
macht jetzt vorweg webseite
wow wo leute das essen ist angekommen
das alles hier ist mein potato bridges
jp sauer und frühlings löring vergeben
probier's mal das essen kein glück ist
gestorben
[Musik]
beschreibe das leben in vier wörtern
leben beschreiben das leben in vier
wurden - das waren 59
nein nein nein ich schreibe das neben in
vier worten oder warum steht dann da
hinten klein eigentlich mein penis groß
[Musik]
[Applaus]
also ich wollte gerade wirklich ganz in
ruhe duschen und dann sehe ich auf
einmal der kleine pc hängt da wieder
alter du sollst dich verloren
[Musik]
ich würde mich nie dafür sprechen dass
indianer also die treue und von wachstum
von henner mahlstedt also in verzug war
sich vor zwei wochen haben uns halt
gedacht dass man einfach sonntag tun mal
zwei wochen hat gegen diese hier nur
dazu und ja das kommt dann
wahrscheinlich die tage in einem neuen
blog 2000 jahre später
[Musik]
ich weiß ehrlich gesagt nicht wieso ich
das jetzt schon gesagt hat dass ich das
mit diesem händler zu machen wollte war
das sollte eigentlich so krank werden so
im titel mein erstes tattoo ist nur ne
[Applaus]
[Musik]
na.de genauso wieder leben man sieben
durchgefallen
norman das übel ist keine neue zähne
finde ich tanke richtig entspannen kann
das ist jetzt mittlerweile irgendwie
viertel vor zwölf und die bestellten
taxi und fahren jetzt ins große haus dh
nächsten aufnahmen auf jeden fall mit
myphone geschossen
hier sehen sie einen studio 71
mitarbeiter der irgendwo rückweg vom
bootshaus und gehen wir den verband mit
dem taxi fahren kann ich habe die bahn
verpasst ländern sind so rein gelaufen
und ich kann sich die rolltreppe runter
weil ich noch telefoniert habe und ich
habe die band verbracht muss sich allein
taxifahrer genaue erklärung zu gerade
ist dass wir halt eigentlich zu fünft
unterwegs waren auf dem rückweg vom
bootshaus
ich habe nicht mitbekommen habe dass die
anderen vier halt so ein bisschen vor
gerannt sind um den ball zu erwischen
weil ich habe telefonieren war und habe
deswegen die war leider nicht bekommen
aber bin halt mit dem taxi zurück
gefahren und habe ich mit dem taxi
fahren über seine bevorstehende hochzeit
und über seinem bett kommenden kinder
unterhalten auch sehr schön deswegen
würde ich sagen die freunde wenn euch
dieser clip gefallen hat einen daumen
hoch freuen und sonst sehen wir uns im
nächsten video video to be
[Musik]